allez on va repartir du côté de
bruxelles a retrouvé karim piron je le
rappelle entrepreneurs et confondateur
de space heidi pour nous parler
justement de la situation actuellement
en belgique puisque le gouvernement
belge a redonné le confie demande de la
population karim piron on l'a dit vous
êtes entrepreneur j'imagine que vous
devez travailler avec l'extérieur de
temps en temps comment vous allez vous
organiser
en fait l'essentiel de notre travail se
fait en extérieur puisqu'on est
considéré comme consultant notre travail
en fait d'analyser la façon dont les
collaborateurs utilisent leur espace de
travail donc on est toujours chez les
clients et donc actuellement nous avons
un but l'ensemble de nos de notre
activité à l'arrêt donc tout a été
arrêté ou reporté puisque les
collaborateurs ont été invités à
effectuer du télétravail à domicile et
donc ne sont plus dans les bureaux en
france le gouvernement a affiché sa
solidarité avec les entreprises qui
comme la vôtre vont subir des des coups
d'arrêt est ce que le gouvernement belge
lui a aussi été rassurant oui plusieurs
choses ont été mises en place par le
gouvernement notamment le report ou les
dispense de cotisations sociales en tant
que paiement pour la tva l'impôt
après le seul petit bémol est que
l'information arrive au compte-gouttes
et puis les choses sont en perpétuelle
évolution puisque forcément à percer des
prêts à une crise de cette ampleur
donc nous en tant qu'entrepreneur on est
chef d'entreprise
on est un peu je veux dire en attente
des compléments d'information et
notamment des petites précisions
puisqu'on sait ce qui est mis en place
mais on ne sait pas pour quelle
situation
est ce que les mesures mises en place
sont d'application est-ce que vous et
peut-être d'autres entrepreneurs que
vous fréquentez vous avez a peur de ce
qui peut se passer vous craignez pour
votre activité
pour le moment on termine cette semaine
en télétravail est donc suite à cette
semaine on a plus de travail et donc
clients ni de projet donc c'est vrai que
l'avenir je veux dire c'est un gros
point d'interrogation on sait pas de
quoi demain sera fait donc on est un peu
dépendant de ses dires de l'est
l'évolution de la situation même des
mesures que le gouvernement combat merci
beaucoup karim pillon d'avoir été avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france
je rappelle que vous êtes entrepreneur
et cofondateur de speyside dit merci
beaucoup